er kam vor fünf jahren nach deutschland
zusammen mit seinem jüngeren bruder flo
tarakuli vor dem krieg in syrien im
gepäck sein diplom
denn ganz von vorne wollte er nicht
anfangen
in seiner heimat hatte er schon einen
beruf gelernt und bei dem wollte er
bleiben
2009 ich habe angefangen mit ausbildung
seitdem habe ich bis jetzt gearbeitet
und diese bereich ich habe als
industriemechaniker ausgebildet und
haben einen firma gearbeitet die kohle
schränke hier stehen hier macht er
vakuum sauger und profitiert von seiner
ausbildung in syrien
er liebt seinen beruf deswegen wollte er
unbedingt seine qualifikationen in
deutschland anerkennen lassen
der weg bis dahin war nicht einfach von
einem amt zum anderen wurde er geschickt
schließlich kam hilfe von der industrie
und handelskammer
dort habe ich alle dokumente gebracht
und gesagt einfach dann die haben mir
gesagt das geht raus
vor diesem problem stehen viele
migranten in deutschland und die die
noch hierher kommen wollen 2018 haben
fast 30.000 menschen einen antrag auf
anerkennung ihrer erworbenen ausbildung
gestellt
eine große herausforderung bei den
anerkennungsverfahren ist tatsächlich
das herausfinden des sogenannten
deutschen referenz berufs wo ich meine
anerkennung stellen kann wenn ich aber
aus einem drittstaat komme dann habe ich
die situation dann brauche ich die
anerkennung zwingend für die einreise
fachkräfte werden in deutschland
dringend benötigt unternehmen wie das
von udo werner sind auf arbeitsmigranten
angewiesen
deshalb ist er froh industriemechaniker
wie tarakuli bei sich zu haben
jemand der so lange können bekommen hat
der kommt ja ganz anders hier hin da
anderes selbstwertgefühl und der ist
einfach hoch motiviert ich gehe zur
arbeit noch mehr zu lernen sich
weiterzubilden
auch die sprache zu lernen das sehen wir
an dem tag sehr deutlich aber der anfang
war für ihn auch nicht leicht er musste
erst einmal die deutsche technik
kennenlernen
doch jetzt arbeitet er selbstständig bin
ich tot
ich kann nicht zu hause sitzen ich habe
immer gewohnt von anfang an libyen habe
ich gearbeitet und bis jetzt habe ich
gearbeitet
das deutsche diplom motiviert den
26-jährigen jetzt will er seine
deutschkenntnisse noch verbessern und
den meister abschluss machen